Mình bố tháng tám, chính quyền Thịt Chánh Sragon, Tình Trung Giá và Ido Nesia, thông báo,
má chăm sóm lắm người đã điện một độc thực phẩm sau khi ăn gửi chưa mẹn phí, tại một chương học trên địa bàn.
Các buôn ăn này nằm trong trường trình bước ăn học đường mẹn phí, gió tầm thầm,
pra buôn sù viện tổ và đốc. Đây là vụ một độc tập thể thứ 2, cho nó này, và lần nghiêm trọng gắt từ cho đến này liên
quan đến trường trình của chính phụ này. Các nạn nhân chủ ỡ lọa học sinh, nói bị đã buộc giữ giới,
tiêu trải và những đậu sau khi chúng bữa, các mẫu thực phẩm như người bị nghiệm đậu đã được gửi đi xem nghiệm,
bao gồm gần ngệch, trường gián, tương nễn, dưới trọng xà lách, tạo lát và sự hộp sau sự viện.
Chính quyền trạm có tà cảm ghét chỉ trả mọi chi phí đậu trị như các thiết.
Đông thầy đình chỉ hoàn độc mẹn tập thể, chú chánh nghiệm chế biển các sớt ăn cho đến khi có kích quả xem nghiệm.
Chương trình của anh mẹn phía của chính phủ i đo need sia được trình khai từ thả một năm nay sau khi ông
Bravo, sự biển tổ nhận chức tổng thống. Chương trình hương đến hơn với làm trường học sinh,
dưới kiến mở dọng cho tàm e bà chụ em và của năm nay với ngân sách mời phải sảo tỷ đo là Mỹ.
Thả năm vừa qua, thân hai chăm học sinh tình, tây ra vá cũng bị ngôn độc tập thể, vì các bự ăn bị cắt lận nhiệm vi khẩn xà môn né là và a cố li.